[Music]
the last of us to may well be coming and
while we don't know anything concrete
just yet if you're willing to take the
following with an enormous grain of salt
here's what we know so far
two days ago Bruce Straley one of the
game directors for the Last of Us posted
a tweet saying I got goosebumps playing
and talking through a prototype a
designer was sketching in yesterday
that's how I know hashtag is gonna be
awesome
the hashtag may not have taken off just
yet but on top of that since we got a
work-in-progress artwork from Merrick
Oakland a freelance concept artists that
worked on several pieces of artwork for
the original game the artwork could be
seen as a grownup le playing guitar
which has the internet rumor mill
churning into overdrive giving Joel and
Ellie did have a conversation about
guitars in the first games there's also
a possibility that this could be related
to the upcoming Naughty Dog art book
though so it might be a good idea to
stay at tabs get school on this one let
us know whether you think this means the
Last of Us 2 is happening or if it's all
just a big coincidence we have reached
out to Naughty Dog for comment and will
let you know where we hear any updates
stay tuned to games but